all right the topic of how to fix the
Democratic Party this keeps coming up in
different ways and the context has been
just the election results of 2016 right
losing to Donald Trump if you're in the
Democratic Party should really make you
question well we we have a problem and
we need to fix it how do we do it a DNC
meddling and this general problem of
corporate Democrats the problem of Tom
Perez is DNC chair sort of continuing
this establishment Democrat problem and
then of course the urgency of
suppressing trumpism right what can
Democrats do in the immediate to try to
prevent or suppress the ideas of the
Trump administration however harebrained
and ragtag they may be and they're
pretty harebrained as we've been
covering for more than nine months at
this point so there's a macro and a
micro here right an example of the macro
that needs to be discussed is Democrats
need to move to the left
Democrats need to take stronger
progressive positions on important
issues micro would be maybe the
super-delegates need to go maybe that's
something that we need to look at and
recently we've actually heard some calls
from some democratic elected officials
saying that super-delegates have to go
Bernie Sanders recently wrote an article
with the same title how to fix the
Democratic Party in Politico and it
included some interesting things some
ideas that I found a little bit less
relevant and I wanted to discuss this
and this is not meant to be
all-encompassing but I'm going to talk
about some of the areas in which
Democrats Inc really needs to shape up
and and the first step in any
intervention is you've got to admit that
you have a problem right and Bernie
Sanders points this out and it's
abundantly true which is the current
strategy just isn't working what I call
Democrats Inc have lost a thousand seats
in state legislatures in the US and I
don't know how many years Republicans
now control the House and the Senate and
more than thirty of the fifty
governorships and of course the White
House and in the end remember we lost to
Donald Trump despite demographics
shifting in the in the favor of the
Democratic Party over the last 15 20
years despite Donald Trump being this
incompetent buffoon appealing to the
lowest common denominator we still lost
as progressives through the Democratic
Party and again I'm not a Democrat but
I'm a progressive and right now I still
see the Democratic Party as a major
conduit to possible progressivism listen
to myself even hedging that language
right it's not good when you lose to
Donald Trump so let's start going
through a list of some things that
Democrats should should do
starting with you gotta fix the DNC
right meaning number one get a real
progressive running it and number two
stop messing with the primaries the DNC
as this unbiased impartial arbiter of
the primary process that's a pipe dream
that was destroyed by what took place in
2016 you got to fix the DNC at the DN
you gotta fix Democrats at the DNC level
number number one number two get rid of
super-delegates super-delegates I get it
right they are there supposedly to
protect against some crazy wacky
insurgent this isn't the Republican
Party right the left-wing equivalent of
Donald Trump isn't going to win the
Democratic primary merely because you
get rid of super-delegates and I believe
it is time for super-delegates to go
number three work endlessly tirelessly
on preventing voter suppression and that
means you also have to work on voter
registration it's sort of a two-part
thing I've said it before the time it
will take you to convince at rumpus not
to his vote for his reelection in 2020
you could get ten people who are already
sort of on the left but may never have
voted out to the polls or at least five
people whatever there's some big
imbalance there in the amount of time
and preventing the voter suppression
right that is a major thing Republicans
have been super upfront about the fact
that they realize the demographics are
increasingly on the side of Democrats do
not let Republicans suppress the vote
and that doesn't mean three months
before the election to start blogging
about irregularities with voting
machines in Pennsylvania right that that
means now that means now we have to be
working on preventing the voters
oppression tactics from succeeding now
let's talk a little bit about policy
right number four on policy move to the
left and this applies to a number of
different issues healthcare there needs
to be a more decided left-wing push
there is a debate to be had about
whether or not the Democratic Party
should make it their platform to have
single-payer health care bill scher for
example and many of you disagreed with
his view and I disagreed with it to a
great extent said bill scher said it's a
mistake for Democrats to say our policy
are our platform is now single-payer our
platform should be improving Obama care
I don't necessarily agree with Bill
sherry you don't have to but what's
clear is you got to move to the left on
health care and it can't be it would be
nice to have a public option if it's
okay but if not we'll get rid of that as
well that's a weak position okay that
can't be the position on health care for
Democrats move left on a living wage
right lots of issues when it comes to
living wage it's not just minimum wage
it's way more when we talk about a
living wage it has to do with cost of
living it has to do with inequality I'm
not gonna get into the minutiae of it
now because this is an overview but on
on a living wage there are a number of
ways that this needs to be approached
and then this gets to this broader issue
that needs to be a core democratic issue
which is number five on my list which is
a focus on economic fairness economic
fairness includes income and wealth
inequality which connects to the minimum
wage but it also includes corruption and
cronyism this swamp draining that of
course the the opposite of which is
actually happening under Donald Trump
the fact that we have two justice
systems in the United States one for the
rich and one for everyone else or maybe
we say one for the poor and then one for
everybody else I don't know exactly how
you want to slice and dice it but we
have at least two economic justice
justice systems rather and that connects
to the war on drugs as well so economic
fairness economic fairness and make it
an issue of patriotism as George Lakoff
has suggests the Democrats should frame
it number six get out of the pragmatism
illusion okay I am a pragmatist
sometimes to such a degree that P
and our audience get irritated with me
but sometimes we fall for the pragmatism
illusion which ends up being a way to
sort of hide corporate Democrats
commitment to the status quo and not
having actual policy ideas that reflect
where the public is which generally is
to the left of the Democratic Party
number seven get away from losing issues
okay and we can debate which issues
those are theirs
those who say gun safety is a losing
issue for Democrats not because it isn't
important but because even after Sandy
Hook with 85 or 90 percent public
approval and President Obama in the
White House and seemingly the best
opportunity to pass 100 percent
background checks it still couldn't be
done and there's this idea that guns and
other issues and we could come up with
the list on another day that there are
losing issues that are only going to get
people to vote against you and won't
really get people to vote with you so
that you've got to get away from those
losing issues and number eight don't
ignore the white working-class now I
want to be really careful with how I
explain this I'm not saying that
democratic policy wouldn't be better for
the white working-class than Republican
policy it would be there's no doubt
about that but the impression in the
last election among many working-class
whites was that the Democrats don't
really care about them I don't believe
that that's true I believe that the
policies of someone like Bernie Sanders
would not only be good for non-white
voters but they would also be good for
working-class white voters but you've
got to make it clear that that's the
case so this is a difficult time to
really make these changes and usually it
doesn't happen this way I've been
reading Hunter s Thompson's book fear
and loathing on the campaign trail which
is about the 1972 campaign of George
McGovern against Richard Nixon the
primary and the eventual loss to Richard
Nixon in 72 and in the book it's
explained that were McGovern this is the
idea of Hunter s Thompson and I think
there's a lot to it we're George
McGovern to have won in November of 1972
he could have completely upended the
structure of the Democratic Party but
the fact that McGovern lost which is
which is what happened
right it made it so that the Democratic
Party immediately went back to the good
old boys stuff and we have to make sure
that we don't see a resurgence and the
Tom Perez selection is DNC chair scares
me in this way that we don't see a
resurgence and a sort of planting of the
feet or burying of the hidden sand away
from the Bernie Sanders direction and
more towards the sort of corporate
Democrats Democrats Inc direction not
exactly an analogous situation but I
think there's a relevant lesson from
1972 in thinking about 2016 and the path
forward we'll go into each of these
points in more detail over the coming
months and in the lead-up to the midterm
election but those are some of my ideas
that I have so far and I'd love to hear
from our audience about it the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership